لاشهر وعرفه تداوم على اخذ جرعاتها
الدوائيه بمركز علاج الاورام السرطانيه
بمدينه بورسودان في ظروف الحرب تمثل جرعه
الدواء هذه نافذه امل لعرفه
من على بعد تطمئن الاهل بحصولها على
جرعتها العلاجيه لكنها تتخوف من تضاؤل فرص
علاجها وندره الدواء بسبب تداعيات الحرب
فعشب على عمل كذلك
لحد ما يجيني من البرد ظروف الحرب انه كان
بيجي بالخرطوم
مركز الاورام السرطانيه بطالب العلاج
استقبل المركز خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
2700 مريض نسبه كبيره منهم وصلت من عاصمه
البلاد الضغط على المركز يفوق طاقته
الاستيعابيه وفوق كل هذا يحذر مسؤولون من
تبعات وخطوره نفاذ بعض الادويه المهمه
داخل المركز حوالي 3 اسابيع نحن فتحنا
67 ملف بين مريض من خارج الولايه
بيستخدموا نفس حصه الدواء اللي كان بتيجي
لمريض الولايه حاليا في ادويه بدت يعني
تنفذ الكميه بتاعتها تدريجيا حسب
استهلاكها العلاج الهرموني
وقف تماما جزء من العلاج الكيميائي وقف
برضه جزء من الادويه الموجهه
انهيار جزء كبير من البنى التحتيه للقطاع
الصحي في الخرطوم جعل المستشفيات في
بورسودان امام تحديات توفير العلاج لمئات
المرضى القادمين من العاصمه كما يفرض هذا
الواقع مسؤوليه اخرى على السلطات الرسميه
لتامين الدواء
قصص الانسانيه والوثائقيه والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات